i was very shy i was very awkward and i
was very insecure because i was made to
believe i was fat and ugly my whole life
i was beat up by kids at school i was
beat up by my mom i was always bullied
so like i was told i was fat and i was
ugly and i believed that up until i was
35 years old man i was very insecure i
mean i i know that when you're a hugely
successful
child star yeah which you were i mean
right like
so
i know that when you're in a school
system and you're the big child star
that there's actually like a bullying
component right even though you have
like insane amounts of power or
popularity or whatever
you're playing you're not in school
you're a celebrity yeah but so it's a
different ballgame you're like the
you're you're the dumb kid because you
leave all the time you're the stupid kid
right you know and you must think you're
special because you get to like not be
here when the rest of us have to slave
away at school all day that's the way
they looked at it it's pretty it's
pretty incredible to me that that uh
you can be bullied in that kind of
situation but then what what
what else to to be
made to believe that you're fat
when you were never fat i was a little
bit chubby like i had like what movie
were you fattest in
um i would say it wasn't like maybe a
movie but i think definitely on the bad
news bears tv series i mean i got a big
round of applause absolutely [ __ ] 70s
yeah i was seven and eight years old
yeah but this is called screwed up in
the head
you know your mom tells you you're fat
you think you're fat i wasn't allowed to
eat in those days she would literally
keep meals from me or like hide the you
know candy and the junk food because i
wasn't allowed to eat it
um so that was then but then even all
the way up until gremlins like look at
me and grandma's i'm filling out those
those pants pretty tight you know i got
like a chubby face i got the little bit
of a belly there gremlins was uh like
84. i was like 83. oh 83 i was shooting
it yeah 83 i was shooting it it came out
in 84.85 and then goonies we shot in 84
and it came out in 85 right right okay
yeah so by goonies i started to lose a
little bit of it and then by standby and
i mean
okay it came into my were you already
doing coke on standby no no no no no no
no i was like those gremlins dude
no no no that no that that didn't start
till okay so the first time i did
cocaine was because my mom was doing it
with somebody on the set of the lost
boys okay this little hot little asian
woman who i was sitting there one night
because i was like falling asleep and i
was depressed because i'm like how the
hell am i gonna stay for these night
shoots i've never done a night shoot i
mean i've done like the friday 13th
night shoots but that was like we come
in at noon we work until midnight and
then you go home because like when
you're a kid they're only going to let
you work so late and then they're going
to call it but like now
i'm still a kid but i'm 14 years old 15
years old you know when you get to those
ages all of a sudden they start treating
you more like you're an adult right
and the work code still applies but
they'll be like oh we're gonna do like a
half day half night so we're coming in
at three in the afternoon and we'll work
until three in the morning and i was
like wait what i i wasn't very good at
that so
i was a little frustrated like how am i
gonna do this how am i gonna stay up all
night and this little asian lady comes
up to me and she's like hey you should
just do what your mom does to stay awake
and i was like what's that and she's
like cocaine and i was like
uh
okay
i wouldn't really know where to go she's
like oh i have it just come to my
apartment we'll do something it'll be
easy and then you'll be fine i was like
oh okay well she makes it sound so easy
and harmless i might as well if my mom's
doing it how bad could it be you know
how old were you uh i was like i said 15
15. yeah when was the first time you did
coke how old were you oh [ __ ] i didn't
do coke until i was
uh
20 i think
yeah late bloomer experience i did it on
my high school lunch break
rookie
my senior year or something like come
over and i did it oh it's bad so i got
okay so the first time i did it sorry
it's a bad experience okay because it
was it was good at first like we did it
we had fun it was like you know we were
talking we're sitting in this girl's
apartment she takes me out driving she
taught me how to drive a stick shift
high on cocaine for the first time um
jones and then and then you know here's
the thing i did one line and i thought
that one line was gonna last forever
we're gonna live forever you know so
that's what i was thinking at the moment
fame um but what happened was
unfortunately i was wrong and it did not
and so i didn't go to sleep in between
when i that whole thing which was like
say six to 12 in the afternoon and then
at 12 i go out with my friend for the
day and then i've got like a four
o'clock call and i never slept anywhere
in between and i've gotta work from four
to four and so then i say to the girl
like hey you know what i have a feeling
this stuff might wear off uh how long
does it take to wear she's like oh it'll
be worn off by the time you go into work
and i'm like well i'm gonna probably
need more than to keep me up she's like
don't worry i'll meet you there i'll
give you some more well that was my
first lesson and people doing drugs are
not very honest
so yeah found out the hard way that she
was full of it and uh waited for her to
show up she didn't show up she didn't
show up she flaked on me she left me
hanging right and so i'm sitting there
like you know showing up for work
getting my costume on like half asleep
like okay i gotta make it through this
she'll be here any minute it's cool and
i'm like calling her texting her i don't
think we had texts in those days that's
a lie i was just calling her um
yeah yeah and she didn't show up like no
response no anything you know i'm
sending a birdie over to her house
um and so she doesn't show up she leaves
me hanging and it's now like eight
o'clock at night and we're shooting the
very first scene that day which happens
to be hold for it wait for it yeah the
big truth justice in the american way
speech scene that everybody remembers
that moment was during this hell so it
was literally at that moment where i'm
like and joel schumacher's like okay so
you're gonna come to this spot you're
gonna stop here you're gonna pause for
two seconds you're gonna deliver the
first part of the line then you're gonna
wait and cory's gonna clear over here
and then jamison's gonna come over to
this point and then when he stops you're
gonna open the magazine you're gonna
look at it you're going to pull it down
to right here and then you're going to
look over at the top i mean like all
these instructions i'm like
hold it
no dude
i did not pull it
it was it was a disastrous
meltdown was like was it clear to
anybody that the drugs were involved
here's what was clear i'm a guy that's
very on my [ __ ] all the time i'm very
efficient i'm very like i try to stay
you know i'm a professional i study the
night before i get all into my
memorization i come in the next day i
know my stuff backwards and forwards you
know impeccable i'm a professional i
don't mess around but all of a sudden i
couldn't remember one thing to the next
that he's telling me to do
and he's looking at me like what is
wrong with you like dude i just said
three times here's the order of the
thing and you just you know i say come
to this mark stop you know freeze turn
around lower the thing and then say
you're lying you're going over here
you're walking past your mark you're not
lowering the thing you're saying you're
lying without even looking at the place
you're supposed to look i'm like uh
okay let's do it again so that happens
like 10 times and eventually joel
schumacher's like okay i don't know
what's wrong with you are you on drugs
are you on drugs feldman is that what's
going on here like totally called me out
and i was like huh i wish i was on drugs
i wouldn't be so screwed up right now no
so
so yeah that was the problem i had no
drugs um so he knew there was something
going on and he fires this was at a time
when uh
when everything was still shot on film
oh absolutely yeah it was all filmed so
to screw up a take was actually kind of
expensive at that time very expensive
yeah and uh you said he fired you yeah
he fired me he fired me right there on
the spot he's like listen fellman i
don't know what's going on with you but
you're fired you need to get your act
together i can't have this on my set i
don't know what's going on but you're
you know coming in all out of it looking
like you're high
duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh
for like two hours
but what happened was they were like
look the only way we're gonna let you
continue is if you get some where's your
mom that was the first question where's
your mom why is she not here why are you
all out of it
somebody needs to answer for this and i
was like um good luck finding her she's
probably off with some crew member in
the bar
wow you know doing
drunk getting laid who knows and so
they couldn't find her they all did like
an apb to try and find my mom nobody
could find her they're like this is a
disaster and then they're like well we
can't really blame it on the kid if he's
got no adult supervision so we've got to
at least give him a chance by like
saying okay you've got to have like some
adult supervision around right and then
if you still mess up then we'll fire you
for real so they decided to see like is
your dad available can your dad come
down my dad couldn't come down because
he had his talent management company
which was basically like a false
management company where it was like
like like the powers remember jg powers
or whatever like where they'd like take
your money and do seminars and like
they'd pick like a hundred people to
like oh yeah you're the best looking one
so you're gonna get a free photo shoot
but everybody else has got to pay 15 000
for that same photo shoot in an acting
class and maybe one day you'll get an
acting part and that was kind of like
his thing but he had my movie posters up
all over the walls and it was called new
talent enterprises and it was like over
on the sleazy part of kawainga there
anyway
so
he was doing that and he didn't have
time to come play babysitter so he says
no i'm not available so they were like
well who can you get up here and that we
called marty weiss and marty weiss was a
guy who had been kidnapping me since i
was 11 years old um he was part of the
science fiction
awards or whatever it was called the
saturn
he was not my agent he was literally
just a stalker hangar on dude that
basically got into my life because he
worked for the saturn awards and was
trying to give me an award so he like
called me up but comes to find out that
he basically gave awards to all of like
or like got in touch with all the steven
spielberg kids so i thought he was just
a big steven spielberg fan big disney
fan he loved all those kids he was he
introduced me to another kid that became
one of my best friends at the time named
jason preston who was in explorers i
don't know if you remember the movie
explorers with uh ethan hawk and river
phoenix but okay yeah that was a joe
dante movie um steven spielberg movie as
well but anyway so so he became friends
with him and then introduced me to him
and he became my best friend up until i
met corey haim a couple of years later
so from like gremlins to lost boys this
kid jason president was my best friend
so anyway come to find out that this
guy's like molesting everybody and so
he's a pedophile and then we find out
that basically well he comes in it's in
you know my book and in my movie and
whatever i want to get into the graphic
stories but let's just say that he took
advantage of the situation
okay
and at that time this was the set of
lost boys
so you are 14
turning 15 turning 15 and like so
incredibly famously at the age of 15
you started the emancipation right so
what happened was like so i okay since
marty it wasn't because marty was there
it was because i was embarrassed and i
was shamed that i went down that road
and i did drugs at all because i was so
anti-drug normally like why did i do
that drugs aside there was like
financial [ __ ] going on all kinds of
[ __ ] yeah but the bottom line is i was
just like dude my life sucks right now i
need to like try and keep this job
because otherwise i'm screwed this is my
only chance of like staying away from
that abusive household you know so
especially now that they realize my
mom's the bad guy like that's the best
news really out of all this is that i
have a chance to get away from my mom
because she was really wretched and your
parents were together they were not
together not together so that was the
point was like right if my dad was gonna
at any point come in and kind of save
the day because at least i knew with him
you know we'd smoke weed together
and he wouldn't kick my ass you know i
mean my mom was just like psycho wanted
to beat me all the time wanted to abuse
me he wanted to do whatever she could to
just like hard drugs and physical
violence or versus everything's pretty
cool right and he's a musician and like
you know like probably hit on all my
girlfriends but whatever you know this
sort of thing um so i went to the dad
but that was after we got back from
santa cruz so once we got back from
santa cruz then my dad says hey here's a
great idea let's get you involved in
this thing called hollywood kids say no
to drugs and you'll be like the
spokesperson because we know you hate
drugs and i'm like perfect so i start
doing that then he introduces me to
pedophile number two
um well actually i'd already met
pedophile number two which was alfie but
he came through the whole because i knew
him from being supposedly bobby
hoffman's son bobby hoffman was the head
of casting for paramount television
and cast me on all of my tv shows
growing up as a kid
and many other kids as well and then he
was living with this dude alfie and
alfie started doing these underage clubs
called alfie's soda pop club so that's
when my mom invited me to go
to alfie's club or whatever his party
with bobby at their house and he's like
out and she's like alfie's gonna come
pick you up so you're very special
you're very lucky because alfie's gonna
come pick you up and take you to this
party so alfie was one then john but
john comes through my dad and so my dad
over at new talent is like hey uh i
can't be on the set with you during lost
boys all the time and i'm really busy
and stuff so i'm gonna get you this
assistant guy who's basically gonna
drive you around and be your gopher and
be your chaperone and beer whatever
because again right the whole reason
joel schumacher wanted to get me
parental guidance and wanted to like
make sure that i was set before he kept
me on board was to make sure that i
didn't get around some flunky who wasn't
going to take it seriously and wasn't
going to care about my best interest
right well so what does my dad do i go
to my dad's for better care and end up
with a new flunky who's also a pedophile
isn't that ironic like every time i get
swapped to somebody it's like another
pedophile so anyway yeah that's how
everybody keeping it in
who are you gonna tell yeah i mean your
parents are the ones that are bringing
them into your life right and by by the
way um nothing happened with the alfie
guy until after i was living with my dad
so when i was living with my mom the
only thing that was happening was that
marty weiss was coming and breaking me
out of my house in the middle of the
night and taking me out on drives but he
never molested me during that time he
was only kidnapping me and we were
having fun together so it didn't look
like anything i would see that's a thing
that's how they get you right they get
your trust by like grooming you right by
being your friend and being like hey i'm
gonna be the cool guy that's gonna get
you out of this bad situation so then
you trust them so how does the
emancipation
uh course how do we get there so so
ironically it's the guy
that
was hired by my dad john grissom who is
the pedophile who says hey you got to
get away from these abusive parents
and they're taking all your money and
they're screwing you over we got to get
you out of this situation chuck went up
for the pedophile because that was a
good call right so he's like so we'll
get you in was it though really who
knows that's the thing because
then he also introduced me to cocaine
because like after that so now that i'm
with him it's like we're hanging out all
the time like oh look at sam kinnison
all these guys at the comedy store
they're like love you let's go hang out
with them and then we walk into their
parties and there's giant mounds of
cocaine on the table 15 year olds should
not have been there in the first place
but he walks me and he's like hey man
this is a party and i'm like cool it's a
party and then like i'm like but i don't
do cocaine and i resisted it for like
the first six months hanging out with
all those guys and then eventually i
just got weak and i was like well they
look like they're all having fun and if
they're having fun i guess they weren't
having a pretty good time at the comedy
store they were
that was before they crossed the
imaginary line so it was all good in the
history you know and is that when
kennison had the house like right up the
hill from the christmas tree crystal
that's right so we were chilling at
crystal so anyway so it was at the crest
hill house actually where i did my first
like not the one for my mom which was
the one time one line but this was like
the first time i actually did did
cocaine okay so john grissom gives it to
me and he's like
oh you got to try now you got to try
crack now you got to try heroin now you
got to try it
so every drug that i ever did
literally was because of the same dude
okay how soon after did you start doing
heroin oh like two years later two years
it was a process but i had to go through
my cocaine phase like where i got really
into coke for a while that was like the
whole thing lasted two years but like
basically i was really into cocaine for
like six months to a year
and then
was like you know i see it destroying
all my friends lives i see it destroying
my life i cross that imaginary line
people are having that talk with me
they're like you don't see you have a
problem you have a problem i'm like what
is the problem i'm staying up for three
four days at a time and we're having a
great time no problem you know they're
like no that's a problem
that is the problem right that pedophile
didn't do everything
to help but he he was the one who said
you've got to get away from your parents
so i can have more control over you and
right along with you and put you on
drugs so i can completely manipulate and
control you i understand but it wasn't
like some superhero right right but did
he did he get you set up with some kind
of attorney because yeah i was
fascinated by the idea yeah
like the idea and the journey
because you were like the first like
child star to legally
like become independent of your parents
before like when you're only 15 years
old that's not the first i believe
drew did it first audrey barrymore she
might have done it first okay so we were
right neck and neck around the same
right yeah i mean it's a pretty big deal
and and and what i read about it
was that you were a bonafide millionaire
at 15 years old but by the time the
court proceedings played out like all
they had to show for all of your
earnings was forty thousand dollars you
got your you did your fact check out
very well done so well let me tell you
how it actually went down so so
basically what happened was
in order to get emancipated i had to be
on my [ __ ] like i had to know what i was
doing i had to be able to like say okay
this is
right because otherwise they're not
going to let you go they want to see a
that you know what you're talking about
you know your finances you know where
you're at and that you're going to be
able to be self-sufficient and provide
for yourself
in the event that they turn over the
power of signature to you right so
um basically what happened was i went
down to the producer's pension health
and welfare which is where everybody
who's an actor their residuals go their
payment their you know futures their
pension it's all put into there's an
accounting it's not part of sag it's a
separate division separate building were
you a producer i was not no no no it's
the producer's pension health and
welfare meaning the producers have to
pay into this pension
for the on the behalf of the actors
right okay so there's a certain amount
of money that accrues so they can ac all
the money that you've earned and then b
see what's left in your accounts because
they're the ones that make sure that
like with the jackie coogan law they
have to put like 15 percent aside from
every paycheck that keeps coming up it's
crazy your parents are only allowed to
blow 85 of your money right exactly but
we're gonna make sure you got a few
cents left don't worry
and that's what is not covered up right
because the way my parents did it which
was super slick because typically like a
manager gets 10 to 15 as you know right
well my my parents were both my managers
and they both took 15 wow so there's
your 30 right there off the top then you
got 40 to taxes i don't know about like
literary then you got your business
manager your agent your agent takes 10
percent business manager takes five
percent wait what's happening where
there's fifteen percent how do they
justify fifteen percent because they
figure they're taking off of work right
that is a bit too much why should those
kids earn anything screw those kids
why wouldn't it be like uh why not a
hundred percent or like no no it should
be yeah yeah kids should get all the
money yeah it should be eighty-five
percent of the kid and like
between all the managers right because
kids doing the work right do they figure
because like their childhood giving up
their freedom
yeah somebody go ahead what's even more
crazy i mean we could talk about the
unfairness of uh
all the all the money being the
commissions but but it's just so
fascinating to me a judge grants you
emancipation and so now you're 15 years
old but you are
not legally an adult right so it's
waving waving the idea of minor so
here's what happens so we go to the
court right and i prove okay so this is
where that comes in we go to producers
pension health and welfare they show me
you have earned a million dollars to
this point at 14 and a half this is
where you're at you've earned a million
dollars however
here's what's in your account right now
and that's where the 40 000 right i mean
you gotta figure if you've earned a
million then that puts you in a pretty
high tax bracket so you can almost
ballpark it at 50 percent goes to taxes
until it fits down
right you know yeah so there's [ __ ]
going on but it wasn't necessarily like
as crazy as a million down to 40
thousand yeah it's pretty bad
explain to a 15 year old like taxes like
look they take out half because
i'm with you it's bad
yeah given your resume at that time you
know like with with goonies kremlin's
last boys like
all of it mork and mindy with robin
williams all of it
it's it feels pretty shocking that you
would only have earned a million dollars
at that point well yeah because they
weren't paying people like they were
these days right like there was no
backhand there was no no no
let me tell you something do you know
what i got paid i'll tell everybody i
got paid for goonies forty thousand
dollars it was that sag scale for a
principal role yeah because we were on
it for six months and all this that's
forty thousand dollars for six months
right and half years later crazy right
that's like slave labor if you think
about it and we're almost where the [ __ ]
we're almost 40 years later and now sag
scale for that kind of roles 65 grand
right exactly
exactly
but that said if you do one movie you
get jumped up to like the million dollar
tax day i mean payday bracket you know
what i mean like you do one movie that's
successful you're getting an offer from
me yeah the kids inspired 15 number one
films and we're still getting like here
license to drive how about a hundred
thousand dollars and i'm like what it's
my name over the damn title and that's
the kind of money we were making it was
terrible it was terrible could you
negotiate were you like told not to do
that or i mean what do you um my my
agents were like william morris at the
time so yeah they probably should have
made sure that that didn't happen right
you would think
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]